TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan
coming to you this week
from our New York office.
Here's your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Getting the best results out
of a machine learning model
requires that you truly
understand your data.
However, ML datasets
can contain hundreds
of millions of data points,
each consisting of hundreds
or even thousands of features.
Working with the
PAIR initiative,
we've released Facets, an
open source visualization tool
to aid in understanding
and analyzing ML datasets.
For more details and some
very cool screenshots,
head on over to the post linked
in the description below.
The 2017 Conference on Computer
Vision and Pattern Recognition
happened in Hawaii this week.
But don't worry if
you couldn't make it.
You can learn more
about the research
we presented from this post.
Last year, we introduced Open
Images, a collaborative release
of about 9 million images
annotated with labels spanning
over 6,000 object
categories designed
to be a useful dataset for
machine learning research.
We just introduced
an update to Open
Images, which contains the
addition of about 2 million
bounding boxes to
the existing dataset,
along with several million
additional image-level labels.
More details and a link to
the GitHub are on the post.
Given the benefits
of Strong Mode
and the large number of
users already using it,
we have decided to make
Strong Mode the standard type
system for Dart.
This will happen
in three phases--
Strong Mode is opt in,
Strong Mode is the default,
and Strong Mode
is the only mode.
For details on how
we are making sure
that you have a smooth
transition to the new type
system, check out the post.
We recently introduced
bolder warnings
to inform users about
newly created web
apps and app scripts
for the G Suite
that are pending verification.
In the coming
months, we'll begin
expanding the verification
process and the new warnings
to existing apps as well.
For screenshots and
tips on getting ready,
take a look at the post.
With Cloud Spanner,
you have direct access
to a horizontally scaling,
cloud native infrastructure that
provides global transactions.
Think apps that involve
payments, inventory, ticketing,
or even financial trading.
Thanks to the Google
Cloud Platform free trial
that offers $300 and credits
for one year and this guide,
you can get your feet wet with
Cloud Spanner in five minutes.
We recently introduced
Transfer Appliance.
With a capacity of up to
1-petabyte compressed,
it helps you migrate your
data to Google Cloud Platform
orders of magnitude faster
than over a typical network.
Simply fill this rackable,
high capacity storage server
from your data center
and then ship it to us.
And we'll upload your data
to Google Cloud Storage.
More details are on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'll see you next week.
Thanks for joining me this
week from New York City.
If you'd like to catch some
of the previous episodes
of The Developer Show,
they're right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]